Katie Taylor won over the weekend she
was an underdog which is kind of
cool yeah because she lost her last one
uh yeah I think the first one that she
fought against her but there was like a
Tik Tok video Conor McGregor reacting to
it he looked like he was just on on
everything oh I was going to say he
looked like he was booming with
enthusiasm on everything whatever dude
which is fine dude he can do what he
wants get your mind out of the gutter
just
be can't be happy anymore Casey is such
a everyone's like oh he's jumping too
high he's on coke if you watch the video
but Casey loves Connor so I get we all
do and we of course but I'm saying Casey
sound like you do Jen